[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend in allen und willkommen an
diesem heißen julitag norbert lehmann
ist auch dabei für den sparzwang und
davon wir beginnen mit dem blick nach
draußen die große hitze bei uns ist sie
vor allem in den innenstädten schwer zu
ertragen weiter im süden etwa bei
bordeaux brennt es jetzt schon seit
einer woche
auf der suche nach verbündeten russlands
präsident putin reist nach teheran und
trifft dort den iranischen und den
türkischen präsidenten
und sorge unser bastia alles eigentlich
wollte borussia dortmund mit seinem
neuen star die bundesliga aufmischen
jetzt wurde bei ihm ein tumor entdeckt
der westen deutschlands bekam heute
schon mal zu spüren was morgen dem
norden und osten blüht die hitzewelle
hat das land im schwitzkasten und wer
jetzt sagt naja ist halt juli der
unterschätzt möglicherweise die
zunehmende häufigkeit von solchen tagen
die
größte hitze gab es auf einer linie vom
saarland über rheinland-pfalz hessen bis
nach nordrhein westfalen mit
temperaturen vielerorts an die 40 grad
duisburg knackte den diesjährigen
hitzerekord mit
39,5 grad am nachmittag in heinsberg
waren es 38,8 grad frankfurt am main
meldete
38,4 tendenz steigend heiko rahmens
berichtet
schülerin der hitze in der essener
innenstadt viele stühle und tische
bleiben leer weil die gäste vor der
hitze fliehen händler machen schon
mittags zu das geschäft lohnt sich nicht
auch der feinkosthändler will heute
früher gehen
normalerweise stehen hier bis 6 uhr aber
heute alle am früher feierabend gemacht
ich werde auch in eine stunde früher
fand morgen kaum schatten und nur wenige
bäume asphalt und beton heizen sich auf
es wird in der sonne fast unerträglich
heiß einige passanten sind trotzdem
unterwegs
ist sehr drücken im moment sehr viel
flüssigkeit brauchen wir da richtig viel
trinken ganz viel trinken und
obst essen ja im schatten aufhalten
besonders heiß ist es heute auch die
straßenbauarbeiter im westfälischen
nordhorn den gesamten tag über arbeiten
sie in der prallen sonne schatten gibt
es kaum
von oben diese 35 euro ab 30 grad
sondern wirkliche 170° verbunden also
andere gehen in der sonne wir haben die
sauna auf baustellen die hitze ist auch
ein problem im kaliber stift in
ingersheim baden württemberg für die
bewohner gibt es wassermelone so sollen
sie zusätzlich mit flüssigkeit versorgt
werden denn die hitze kann besonders für
ältere menschen schnell gefährlich
werden
ein bisschen bewundern darauf achten
dass der kreislauf einfach in schwung
bleibt ja dass der
kreis habe einfach auch in gang kommt
gerade morgens und mittags versuchen wir
die beine nach oben zu legen hohe
temperaturen und wenig regen das lässt
auch den pegelstand des rheins weiter
fallen noch läuft der schiffsverkehr
aber nur wenn die schiffe halb beladen
sind und sie so weniger tiefgang haben
waren wir draußen nach bei unserem
meteorologin katja horneffer übermorgen
ist die extreme hitze wohl erstmal
überstanden aber damit ist das problem
ja nicht vom tisch
allerdings die hitzewellen kommen immer
früher und betreffend größere gebiete
und wie man an süd europa sieht halten
sie auch länger durch und in den
hitzewellen wird es einfach immer heißer
das ist genau das was wir im zuge des
klimawandels erwarten können und im
ungünstigsten klima szenario wird es
gegenüber heute bis zum ende des
jahrhunderts doppelt so viele sommertage
also tage mit mehr als 25 grad geben
vier mal so viele heiße tage tage mit
mehr als 30 grad und 20 mal so viele
tropennächte nächte in denen die
temperatur nicht unter 20 grad sinkt
was es mit der ozonbelastung aktuell wie
gefährlich ist die
wir haben heute schon einige stationen
gehabt die 180 mikrogramm pro kubikmeter
luft gemeldet haben zum glück wird das
ja nicht von langer dauer sein denn
schon zum wochenende sind die
ozonkonzentrationen wieder niedriger
eben auch die temperaturen dankeschön
katja eine für diese informationen
gerade städte und ballungsräume müssten
sich viel besser auf die hitze
vorbereiten das sagen experten seit
jahren
der bund stellt dafür nun auch weitere
176 millionen fördergelder bereit und es
gibt beispiele die zeigen dass es geht
mit viel grün aus freiburg berichtet
dorothea dörner
skifahren verboten aber fürs skifahren
ist diese wiese auch nicht angelegt das
dach einer sporthalle in freiburg ist
beispiel dafür die gebäude sich der
klima erwärmung anpassen können susanne
knospe ist projektleiter wenn das klima
anpassungs konzept sind freiburg zum
konzept gehören auch tiefer gelegte
pflanzen biete das gehört zu dem schwamm
stadt konzept der klimawandel zeigt wir
haben immer weniger wasser und das ist
unterschiedlich verteilt die städte
müssen ein schwamm werden der das wasser
aufnimmt und dann abgibt wenn es regnet
läuft das wasser in das beet und wässert
den baum der baum liefert schatten und
verdunstungskühlung und diese kühle
braucht die stadt das demonstriert
susanne knospen einem stein der
stundenlang in der sonne lag in der
nacht wird er diese wärme auch abgeben
das ist der städtische wärme insel
effekt den wir nur in griff kriegen wenn
wir so was haben nämlich bäume bäume
bäume alle paar meter wurden buchen
gepflanzt für das klima und für den
schatten hitzetage sind nicht nur in
zubetonierten innenstädten ein problem
sondern deutschlandweit
diese hitze entlastung die der mensch
braucht das ist ja so ein dreiklang ja
was braucht man was hilft bei hitze des
ist wind das wasser und dieses schatten
und diese drei punkte die finden sich
auch in einer stadt im öko und
vorzeigestadt teil wobei hat man die
hitze gut im griff begrünte dächer alter
baumbestand und pflanzen an den fassaden
sorgen für abkühlung hitze hotspots sind
weiterhin die innenstädte der
wassermangel ist auch hier zu spüren
noch laufen die brunnen auch sie sind
teil des konzepts um sich abzukühlen
unsere städte und die hitze damit
befasst sich auch heute live um 19 uhr
30 zu sehen auf unseren social media
kanälen und in der zdf- heute- m dort
können sie auch nachlesen welche
auswirkungen die hitze auf unseren
körper hat
diese hitze zieht sich quer durch europa
in großbritannien ist es heiss wie nie
erstmals über 40 grad das hat den
bahnverkehr zum teil lahmgelegt in
griechenland portugal italien und
spanien brennen schon seit tagen wälder
besonders heftig an der französischen
atlantikküste eine arendt hat mir
seit einer woche stellen sich mehr als
2000 feuerwehrleute den flammen entgegen
die sich durch die pinienwälder im
hinterland der atlantikküste fressen
der wind bereitet uns die größten
probleme er ist der feind in diesem
kampf gegen das feuer
auf dem trockenen boden lassen sich die
brände kaum bändigen
34.000 menschen mussten bislang in
sicherheit gebracht werden anwohner und
urlauber ihre bleibe verlassen
ich kenne solche bilder sonst nur aus
den medien und jetzt trifft es plötzlich
mich das ist schwer zu realisieren
das feuer breitet sich wie ein krake aus
über mehrere arme um den flammen nicht
noch mehr angriffsfläche zu bieten
werden nun vorsorglich schneisen durch
den wald geschlagen
wir müssen diese zonen breiter machen
denn das feuer ist zerstörerisch die
situation macht uns große angst
mehr als 19.000 hektar wald sind bereits
verbrannt mit sorge blicken sie hier auf
die kommenden tage hoffen dass ein
wetterumschwung besserung bringt
zur politik russlands präsident putin
will die diplomatische und
wirtschaftliche isolation durch den
westen durchbrechen er sucht allianzen
und verbündete heute in teheran
da trifft er sich mit irans präsident 30
und mit dem türkischen staatschef
erdogan alle drei länder stehen
wirtschaftlich unter druck alle drei
menschen mit in den krisen des nahen
ostens vor allem in syrien was aber noch
lange nicht heißt dass sie dort an einem
strang ziehen über das treffen league
weiter
russlands präsident putin auf seine
zweite auslandsreise seit dem beginn des
angriffskrieges gegen die ukraine im
februar es geht zunächst einmal um
syrien wo russland und iran politisch
und militärisch den machthaber assad
stützen die türkei hingegen
islamistische oppositions milizen schon
am morgen hatten irans präsident 30 und
sein türkischer amtskollege erdogan
wirtschaftsabkommen unterzeichnet
teheran und ankara wollen in den
bereichen technologie energie und
wehrtechnik stärker zusammenarbeiten
auch ein versuch die hohe inflation und
die wirtschaftskrise in beiden ländern
etwas einzudämmen
wir wollen unser gegenseitiges
handelsvolumen von siebeneinhalb
milliarden auf 30 milliarden dollar
vervierfachen
doch wurde auch deutlich wo die
eigeninteressen bei diesem gipfel liegen
erdogans pläne für weitere türkische
militäroffensiven in syrien lehnte
teheran entschieden ab
wirtschaftsbeziehungen ja politische
vielleicht mit diesem vorsatz und
einigen geschenken ist auch putin
angereist so wird russlands
energiekonzern gazprom für 40 milliarden
dollar die iranischen förderanlagen
modernisieren über politische
zugeständnisse verlautete bislang nichts
neben syrien werden die staatschefs am
abend auch über die folgen des kriegs in
der ukraine sprechen ein thema die
schaffung von sicheren see korridoren
zum export ukrainischen getreides
verhandlungen darüber soll noch in
dieser woche unter beteiligung der
vereinten nationen in istanbul
fortgeführt werden erdogan möchte am
abend im direkten gespräch mit putin
dessen zustimmung zu den getreide
ausfuhren erreichen
wollen wir unsere korrespondentin in
moskau dazu für begann warum ist dieser
auftritt für putin wichtig
während putin all seine militärische
kraft in seine sogenannte
spezialoperation in der ukraine steckt
muss eben aufpassen dass ihm der in den
letzten jahren sehr kostspielig
aufgebaute einfluss in syrien und im
nahen osten nicht aus den händen gleitet
bislang sitzt russland eben mit am tisch
wenn der iran und auch wenn die türkei
über syrien und das vorgehen dort
verhandeln und wenn ein präsident putin
sein gesicht und seine machtstellung
nicht verlieren will dann muss das aus
seiner sicht eben auch unbedingt zu
bleiben außerdem braucht russland
aufgrund der westlichen sanktionen neue
starke partnerschaften der bitter
präsident sicherlich ausloten wollen was
da mit teheran möglich ist und nicht
zuletzt muss putin verhindern dass der
iran sein öl günstiger am weltmarkt
verkauft als russland noch ganz kurz es
gibt meldungen dass durch nord stream 1
wieder eine geringe menge aus gas an gas
aus russland kommt wie ist es
einzuschätzen
genau also auf der homepage von gazprom
da kann man sehen dass heute nachmittag
zwischen 14 und 15 uhr ein ganz kleines
bisschen gas geflossen ist aus moskau
sagt in moskau sagt man dazu offiziell
nichts und lässt so allen gerüchten und
spekulationen extra viel raum so kann
man dann die nervosität die das in
deutschland anheizt hier genüsslich
auskosten also ob nach abschluss der
wartungsarbeiten wieder in gewohntem
umfang gas durch nord stream 1 geliefert
wird das werden wir abwarten müssen
dankeschön nach moskau havanna
in der ukraine entlässt präsident
selensky neben dem geheimdienst leiter
weitere hochrangige mitarbeiter unter
anderem den vize-chef vorwurf gegen die
behörde hunderte fälle von kollaboration
mit moskau unterdessen beschossen
russische truppen erneut städte im osten
kramer tomsk mindestens ein mensch wurde
getötet und im süden das umland von
odessa moskau sagt ein munitionslager
sei getroffen worden die ukraine spricht
dagegen von einem angriff auf zivilisten
und von sechs verletzten
der ukraine krieg muss möglichst zeitnah
eingefroren werden das sagt sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmer cdu für die
ukraine werde es bitter sein in solche
gespräche zu gehen doch das heiße nicht
dass man sich unterwerfe dass man
gebiete abtreten
mit seiner forderung stellt sich
kretschmann offen gegen die
bundesregierung und gegen die linie
seiner eigenen partei
der krieg in der ukraine ist ein grund
für die hohe in aktion für die eurozone
lag die teuerungsrate im juni bei 8,6
prozent ein rekordwert es wird erwartet
dass die europäische zentralbank auf
ihrer nächsten sitzung übermorgen
reagiert und die leitzinsen anhebt
die ukraine hofft noch darauf für
albanien und nord mazedonien ist das
jahrelange warten jetzt vorbei ihre
eu-beitritts verfahren sind eröffnet
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
bezeichnete den schritt als historischen
moment der beitrittsprozess der beiden
balkanländer kann jedoch noch jahre
dauern und im zweifel auch wieder
gestoppt werden
schauen wir noch auf ein kulturereignis
das mit seiner wucht jedes jahr tausende
ans ufer des bodensees lockt bei den
festspielen in bregenz prallen ab morgen
kulturen aufeinander österreichische
opulenz trifft italienische opern
classic amerikanische freiheit
japanische tradition kurz madame
butterfly wie das aussieht und klingt
zeigt claudio armbruster
ein großes publikum braucht eine große
bühne und eine große bühne braucht große
bilder puccinis madame butterfly am
bodensee viele der bühnenbilder im kult
status bekommen das auge von tosca den
kopf ein genie der kopf von rigoletto
und das möchte ein künstlerisch
schaffende menschen mit opa umgeht
möchte das gerne auch umsetzen können
die liebe der japanischen gescher zum
amerikanischen marine leutnant
heiße liebe in einem sehr heißen sommer
manchmal war es sehr heiß den proben auf
der seebühne aber ich wusste er am ende
des proben tages kann ich einfach in
diesen schönen serien hüpfen und
schwimmen
[Musik]
der oper zu machen für 7000 menschen
einen monat lang jeden abend das ist
schon das erreicht man sonst in europa
nicht
[Musik]
natürlich endet alles tragisch ab morgen
den ganzen sommer lang am boden sehen
[Musik]
manchmal tritt fußball ganz schnell in
den hintergrund norbert im fall von
sebastian halle an der dem neuzugang
allerdings hatte gestern nach dem
training über unwohlsein geklagt bei
einer intensiven medizinischen
untersuchung oder dann ein tumor
entdeckt noch unklar ob es krebs ist ein
schwerer schock für den neuen
bvb-torjäger und für den ganzen verein
im trainingslager in bad ragaz ist die
euphorie die den bvb zuletzt umgab jäh
gebremst wir drücken jetzt sebastian der
gesamten familie hat die daumen
dass er so schnell wie möglich wieder
gesund wird sebastian alea ist
unmittelbar nach der ersten diagnose der
ärzte vor ort zurück nach dortmund
gereist zu weiteren speziellen
untersuchungen beim medizin check vor
der vertragsunterzeichnung
war die erkrankung nicht festgestellt
worden der check ist in der bundesliga
zwar vorgeschrieben sieht aber keine
krebsdiagnostik vor bislang in den
sozialen netzwerken dankte der 28
jährige für die zuneigung und
unterstützung er werde sich jetzt auf
seine genesung konzentrieren um stärker
zurückzukommen
das deutsche diskuswerferin trio steht
im wm-finale von eugene kristin pudenz
die olympia zweite klo dean witter mit
der besten weite in der quali und
shanice craft ja enttäuschung dagegen
bei hochsprung europameister mateusz
przybylko der leverkusener erreichte im
finale nur rang zwölf
der letzte versuch von mateusz przybylko
über zwei meter 27 unter zeitdruck den
ersten anlauf hatte er abgebrochen und
jetzt das aus die gründe dafür
vielschichtig der boden ist nicht gut
das ist nicht richtig wir haben aber
wissen welches heute verhalten wie
gesagt auch nicht mein tag seinen tag
hatte er bei der em 2018 in berlin der
sprung über 235 zum europameistertitel
sogar zwei meter 37 sprüngen bei dieser
wm der sieger good as essa barshim aus
katar tebogo mit zwei meter 24 zwölfter
bei der em in münchen will er wieder
angreifen und
noch zu tode fonds 16 etappe von
carcassonne nach sieger nach 178 5
kilometer der kanadische radprofi
das zweite mal dass überhaupt ein
kanadier eine tour etappe gewinnt der
berliner simon geschke verteidigte das
gepunktete trikot als bester bergfahrer
ja und soeben melden noch die bayern der
wechsel von verteidiger die licht nach
münchen ist perfekt das doch schön für
die bayern katja horneffer berichtet
hier gleich wie es mit hitze und
trockenheit weitergeht viertel vor zehn
freut sich christian sievers auch sie im
heute journal und wir danken für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen noch einen
schönen angenehmen abend das machen auch
wieder weg
[Musik]
guten abend war es war das heiß heute
und morgen wird es noch mal heißt dann
aber vor allen dingen dem osten
deutschlands die hoffnungen ruhen auf
dieser kleinen kaltfront die bringt
regenschauer und gewitter mit aber viel
zu wenig regen um der dürre einhalt zu
gebieten die kommende nacht wird
tropisch häufig sinken die temperaturen
nicht unter 20 grad und besonders
belastend wird es in den großen städten
nordrhein westfalens bleiben denn da
liegen die temperaturen bei 23 grad
angenehmere nachttemperaturen finden sie
an der ostsee und in bayern bei 14 bis
13 grad und morgen erreicht die hitze
blase den nordosten in hamburg richtung
sachsen anhalt in berlin brandenburg und
in thüringen können bis zu 40 grad
erreicht werden im westen ist es dabei
28 bis 30 grad schon kühler aber das
wird schwer sein und uns auch sehr
unangenehm vorkommen denn von westen
kommen schon die ersten regenschauer
heran und nachmittags und zum abend
weiten die sich dann aus da können auch
unwetter dabei sein also gewitter die
mit hagel starkregen und sturmböen
verbunden sind die ziehen über
rheinland-pfalz weiter nach nordrhein
westfalen und auch von baden württemberg
weiter richtung bayern in den nächsten
tagen geht es längst nicht mehr so heiß
weiter am samstag liegen die werte bei
18 bis 32 grad guten abend